one of the things that I think can be
hard for people approaching Coward now
is because so many of his plays are
written in a in a high comedy style
that's a style that's getting lost in
the transition in the translation how is
it for you as an actor to try and
reinforce I feel very comfortable with
that it's maybe I'm old enough to really
feel like I know what that place and
time was and I have been instructed a
lot by the movies to know what the
delivery needs to be for me it's just a
matter of of working on the technical
sides of things more than anything to
try and present it in a coward esque
style you know I think the speech we all
know has to be pristine and pure and
beautifully spoken and completely
enunciated and that is something that
today's mostly younger actors aren't
familiar with so it demands a lot of a
lot of concentration on the execution
just of the speaking in my mind a lot of
exercises lips teeth tip of the tongue
and a lot of a lot of vocal lip and
tongue exercises to make sure that you
are able to really control your speech
at a brisk speed and make sure you hit
all those caves and T's and DS and those
are the kinds of things that aren't
emphasized that much in our more
Stanislavski oriented system so those
are the kinds of things that I start out
with trying to to look at because I feel
that so often the the thrust of what is
being said and the scene is is the arc
of the scene is is pretty clear it's not
like it has some deep subtext so it's
mostly just getting the words out there
and letting Coward's brilliant words
carry the day and tell the story I think
that he's similar
to intimate in many ways to shah who
often spoke of his work as being musical
and an aria and I think because Noel
Coward was such an incredible musician I
think that his words and his dialogue
have a sense of music about them and and
so I think that if you you if you have a
sense of musicality about you that
really serves you well in terms of
trying to find the the lilt and the
movement of what he's written but I do I
would say that Shah requires the same
kind of attack
just off the top of my head mm-hmm is it
fun being cowards absolutely but I can't
emphasize enough how much energy it
takes you can't sit back on your heels
and do that it requires such such energy
such the precision alone the focus the
concentration is so intense it's fun but
it's it it really takes a lot of focus
are there any coward roles you would
still like to play do you have a
favorite from the shows that you did
well I love playing madam Arkady implied
spirit
I had it all doing that and that was a
big favorite yeah wonderful thank you so
much for being here
it's wonderful to get an actor's
perspective